[Music]
when you're learning something new your
tendency is to think I'm an impostor I'm
just kind of a fake I am not nearly as
good as all these other people who are
very far ahead of me and in working on
whatever you're trying to get started
working on and this is one of the best
best traits you could have embrace your
inner impostor because what the impostor
syndrome does that feeling that you're a
fake and you're not as good as everyone
else is it allows you to open your
beginner's mind so you start looking at
things with a more open and receptive
way because well part of it is you're
really unsure of yourself and so you're
really paying attention and really
listening people who approach a new
discipline with you know I'm just really
confident I can do this which is often
the message we hear from society you
should be confident about yourself and
your skills and so forth it can close
you off to sort of correcting your
mistakes and being humble and
approaching things almost from a lower
perspective or a lower start then you
might think you have to start at just
because if you start really low really
humble you really get the background
that you you need in order to excel and
achieve at whatever you want to excel
and achieve that when it comes to
learning something there it almost seems
like there's two types of learners one
of them is what I might term a waste car
learner they've got these waste car
breeds they get there really fast and
the other is more like a hiker a hiker
gets to the finish line but much much
more slowly think about it this way you
know it's depressing if you're a slow
thinker to look at these faff thinkers
race car brains and realize they can get
anywhere much
quickly than you but think about what a
hiker experiences as opposed to the
racecar driver the racecar driver
lose Willie fastest to the finish line
everything's a blur
a hiker can reach out they can touch the
leaves on the trees they can see the
little rabbit trails they can smell the
air hear the birds completely different
experience and in some ways far richer
and deeper so it can help you sometimes
if you're a slow thinker you think
there's nothing in it for me I'm not as
fast as these other people you can
sometimes see things that those really
really fast thinkers miss just because
you're looking more people
[Music]